bonjour merci pour l'instruction donc on
va finir la journée dans l'espace
vous savez que toutes les activités
humaines créent et produisent des
déchets eh bien c'est la même chose dans
l'espace et donc je vais vous parler des
affaires de débris spatiaux
alors pour commencer une petite
animation qui vous représente
l'évolution au cours du temps du nombre
d'objets catalogué en orbite autour de
la terre
objet catalogage sont les objets de plus
de dix centimètres qui sont répertoriés
par les moyens de surveillance et qui
sont cathos louis afin qu'ils sont
répertoriés individuellement
donc vous voyez l'évolution donc il ya
c'est clair et en particulier ce qu'on
voit c'est un encombrement relativement
important un orbite basse à proximité de
la terre et on voit également ici se
dessiner l'orbité géostationnaire qui
est à 36 mille kilomètres l'altitude sur
l'équateur terrestre alors ce qu'il faut
dire également c'est que ces objets ne
sont pas suspendues en l'air comme ça
ils sont à north beach est un objet en
orbite se déplace à grande vitesse à
norwich basse la vitesse orbitale et 8
km par seconde
huit kilomètres par seconde ça fait vous
faites le calcul ça fait de l'ordre de
28 mille kilomètres à l'heure
c'est dix fois la vitesse d'une balle de
fusil donc tous ces objets tombent dans
tous les sens à très grande vitesse
alors où en est-on aujourd'hui
depuis 1957 il a eu un peu plus de 5000
lancement chaque lancement injecte en
orbite plusieurs objets les tâches du
lanceur bien sûr les charges utiles des
satellites bien sûr des éléments de
structure et c'est donc le nombre
d'objets injecté par ses 5000 enfants et
on a malheureusement observer plus de
200 fragmentation plus de 220
fragmentation de l'espace
volontaire ou accidentel qu'on crée
beaucoup de débris voilà donc je voulais
vous montrer cette la situation
aujourd'hui on a d'une part les objets
les gros objets plus de 10 cm il y en a
environ 20000 et vous avez la
répartition ici des objets les
satellites utile c'est à peu près 5%
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya
environ mille satellite qui servent à
quelque chose qui sont utiles
tout le reste sont des objets inutiles
des bruits en particulier des fragments
plus de la moitié des objets dans
l'espace sont des des morceaux des
fragments on a 20 % de satellites
abandonnés
donc ça fait à peu près 4000 satellites
abandonnés des étages de lanceurs qui
ont servi à injecter ces charges utiles
14%
et puis là les appelle les débris
opérationnel ce sont les objets qui ont
été volontairement libéré au cours
d'émissions
donc ça c'était les gros objets bien sûr
les objets plus petits sont encore plus
nombreux entre 1 et 10 cm on à
l'estimation de 300 mille objets et puis
encore plus petit plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'objets entre 1 mm et 1 cm
alors sur cette courbe on a représenté
le l'évolution au cours du temps du
nombre d'objets cataloguées depuis
soutenu depuis 1957
donc on va s'intéresser uniquement la
courbe de marolles qui la somme de ses
composantes a donc depuis 1957 le nombre
d'objets catalogué augmenté aujourd'hui
en année on est autour de 15 mille ha
devrait donc ce qu'on observe c'est une
croissance permanente de ce nom de
l'objet avec quelques quelques creux
quelques bosses sur la courbe que vous
voyez on a eu en en 1986 l'explosion
d'un étage ariane legault lever 16 qui a
explosé après neuf mois en orbite donc
en créant quelques dit oui mais
finalement c'est pas le plus grave
puisque le l'atmosphère ensuite fait le
ménage et les objets sont retombés assez
rapidement alors plus graves
c'était en 2007 en janvier 2007 quand
les les chinois ont fait un essai
d'armes antisatellites ils ont détruit
volontairement le 7 et un guillaume 1
c'est donc en créant pas mal des débris
plus de 2500 gros gros objets et ensuite
en février 2009 on a eu une collision
dans l'espace entre deux satellites
iridium 33 et cosmos 22,51 donc aussi
créé pas mal de pommes de débris
donc voilà la situation aujourd'hui
alors quelques mots sur les risques
maintenant tout d'abord anne orbite
comme ces objets sont animés de vitesse
importante le risque bien sûr c'est un
risque
deux collisions entre des objets vu le
vu la vitesse l'énergie cinétique des
objets même très petit et très
importante et un objet de 1 mm peut
perforer les structures dans cette élite
donc là vous avez un exemple sur les cds
cellule solaire du télescope spatial de
hubble donc un petit impact qui a
perforé une cellule donc ce n'est pas
forcément très grave mais ça dépend de
les conséquences en variable suivant
l'endroit où la perforation lave avoir
lieu une perforation sur eux sur une
antenne par exemple c'est pas c'est pas
gênant une perforation sur un boîtier
électronique ça peut devenir plus
embêtant un autre exemple sur la navette
spatiale
c'est un ici un trou sur le bord
d'attaqué des ailes d'une navette
spatiale et on sait depuis l'accident de
columbia que le les bords d'attaqué des
ailes sont les protections thermiques
sont importantes parce que lors de la
rentrée
ça permet d'arrêter le flux de chaleur
est sous la protection thermique
il y a les élèves qui sont en aluminium
et donc on risque d'endommager la
structure à notre exemple sur les sur un
hublot de la navette spatiale
au cours des opérations de la nasa en
moyenne changer un hublot par mission à
cause impacts de débris ou météorite sur
les blu
ensuite les les objets plus gros
quelques centimètres la l'impact est une
seconde nous on appelle une collision
létale parce que dans ce cas-là
l'énergie de la collision est tel que
l'ondé de choc se propage la structure
et que le satellite est perdu la mission
est terminée
et aujourd'hui on n'a aucun blindage
capable d'arrêter ce type de particules
à partir de centimètres li ss la station
internationale est protégé jusqu'au vert
de 2,3 cm alors justement un exemple sur
sur les ss c'était un impact de quelques
millimètres de 5 mm donc cet impact est
sur un rail située à l'extérieur de la
station
donc vous voyez le trou qui a été fait
est ce cet exemple a permis d'expliquer
pourquoi lors des sorties
extravéhiculaires les a30 revenait d'un
dans la station avec l'élégant qui était
endommagé donc on a compris que c'était
à cause des bords du cratère ici de
l'impact qui déchirait les gants dix
astronautes
bon si on augmente la taille si on
regarde les objets à partir de la
dizaine de centimètres là il s'agit pour
nous de collisions qu'on appelle
catastrophique parce que non seulement
les deux objets sont détruits par la
collision
mais si la production d'un très grand
nombre de débris sur les images
représentent la collision iridium cosmos
la de 2009 donc on voit les deux nuages
de débris qui ont été créés par cette
collision
donc une double conséquence la perte des
deux véhicules bien sûr mais aussi d'une
pollution importante des orbites
alors voici là une illustration de la
première collision entre objets
catalogué qui a eu lieu dans l'espace
c'était en 1996 en juillet 1996 et
c'était une collision franco-française
le satellite le micro-satellite cerise
qui a été endommagée par un débris qui
venait de l'explosion de laitages
d'ariane v 16
donc vous voyez ce résister équipé d'un
homme qu'on appelle un mât de gradient
de gravité une perche de stabilisation
en fait pour conserver le latitude
verticale local du satellite est donc ce
mât a été coupée en deux par un débris
issus ariane
alors ces collisions bien sûr est restée
célèbre et en particulier nos amis
américains se sont fait un plaisir de de
communiquer beaucoup sur cet événement
puisque c'était en plus c'est un
satellite militaire français endommagée
par un des bruits français alors je vous
ai dit quelques mots sur les risques en
orbite
il ya aussi des risques au sol puisque
tous les objets qu'on lance un jour
l'autre vont finir par rapport à
décembre et part aux retombées alors
quelques exemples d'objets qu'on a pu
récupérer sur terre suite à dire en
traitement sphérique
là ça c'est un réservoir de lanceur
américain delta 2 qui retombait au texas
bond de 150 kilos c'est un joli morceau
du même lanceur ça c'est les tuyères la
partie du bloc moteur et des tuyères qui
sont dimensionnés justement pour
résister aux températures donc ça
résiste très bien la rentrée et on a
retrouvé au sol ça aussi c'est un un
morceau de delta 2 qui a été retrouvé
dans la banlieue de bangkok
donc sans faire de victime et ça c'est
un morceau d'ariane retrouver au brésil
une sphère en titane de 40 kg donc
jusqu'à présent on n'a jamais eu
d'incident mais il faudrait pas trop
continue longtemps ce genre de choses
alors que peut-on faire quand on a vu
cette situation il n'y a pas beaucoup de
solutions n'y a pas cinquante solutions
premièrement il faut mieux connaître la
situation dans l'espace de il faut
essayer de vivre avec de se protéger le
vivre avec 3 bien sûr ne plus créer des
oui et puis 4 à terme il faudrait faire
du nettoyage
alors le premier point les affaires de
connaissance de situations c'est les
affaires de survie en espace le la
connaissance est obtenue aujourd'hui par
des moyens radars ou optiques
essentiellement des moyens militaires
puisque le le besoin le principal besoin
c'est un besoin militaire de
connaissance des objets qui sont bons
qui circule de l'eau
donc ce sont des moyens optiques ou
radar en général au sol parfois
embarqués à bord deux satellites
bon ce qu'il faut aussi savoir c'est que
la principale sur un fossé le réseau
militaire américain donc là sûr si vous
allez sur internet vous trouverez le
le catalogue des objets qui est
disponible sur internet et puis quelques
moyens ailleurs en france nous avons
géré présenté ici les images
le radar de surveillance grave un
télescope du cnrs et un bateau de la
marine qui a quelques quelques jolis
radars mais c'est pas grand chose
comparé au moyen américain de
surveillance au deuxième rang se
protéger sur le schéma en haut à droite
j'ai représenté le principe d'un
blindage le blender ça consiste empilés
plusieurs couches pour que la première
couche fragmenter la particule ainsi
lente l'énergie et dispersés sur une
surface plus grande qui vient endommagé
la deuxième part au à l'énergie encore
dispersés sur une surface sur une
surface plus grande et on peut espérer
que la paroisse de la station spatiale
va résister aux impacts de débris crée
donc les blindages vous l'avez compris
tout de suite c'est une question de
matériaux de de masse en pratique les
satellites ne sont pas blindés
on ne blême que les clés des véhicules
habité et la station spatiale alors
autres autres moyens de protection
c'est essayer d'éviter les collisions
bon ça se fait maintenant de manière à
peu près classique sur les satellites
on essaie de prévoir les rapprochements
et lorsque le risque est jugé trop
important
une manoeuvre est effectué pour passer à
10 ans de sécurité ça se fait aussi au
moment du lancement lancement depuis
kourou
il serait dommage d'aller en plafonner
la station spatiale par exemple au
moment du lancement
donc on regarde ce type de de risque et
à ce moment là il suffit de modifier
légèrement leur de tir si on retarde le
tir comme la terre entre temps un petit
peu tourné on obtient une trajectoire
qui différentes équipes qui va passer à
d'essence de sécurité de
de la station spatiale alors en ce qui
concerne ensuite les risques au sol
l'aller les moyens d'action sont assez
limitées puisque la plupart des objets
retombe de manière incontrôlée et il
faut savoir qu'on a en moyenne 1 un gros
objet qui retombe par semaine gros
objets c'est à dire c'est un étage du
lanceur ou satellite par semaine de
manière incontrôlée donc on ne peut pas
et les prévisions sont assez difficiles
à faire donc c'est pas très utile la
solution à terme ça sera d'arriver à
faire des rentrées contrôler c'est à
dire de choisir au moyen d'une manoeuvre
de d'orbites de choisir le point de
chute de l'objet et faire retomber
l'objet de dans un océan mais c'est
relativement compliquée est relativement
cher
or aujourd'hui la priorité c'est les
mesures de prévention la principale
action c'est de réduire la produit la
production de débris on a identifié des
zones à protéger d'urgence donc l'orbité
basse comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure
et puis leur bigelow ici le principe de
mesurer et rappeler ici
la première des choses à faire bien sûr
ce ne plus créer des oui non plus largué
volontairement des objets dans l'essai
le moins possible aux les autres mesures
concernent principalement la gestion de
la fin de vie des satellites et les
lanceurs
une fois que l'objet a fini sa mission
quand il est en orbite basse aujourd'hui
nous avons une règle qui est ce qu'on
appelle règles étaient 25 ans un orbite
basse
on accepte que l'objet après la fin de
sa mission reste pas plus de 25 en
orbite
bon je suis d'accord c'est pas c'est pas
parfait on peut espérer que dans
quelques années on passera à 20 ans ou
15 ans on réduira ce délai
aujourd'hui la pratique ses 25 ans en
orbite géo en est vraiment très loin de
la terre on est à trente six mille
kilomètres ici donc là il est plus
question de revenir sur terre on est
beaucoup trop loin ça demanderait
beaucoup trop d'énergie
et la solution retenue qui est encore
une fois loin d'être parfaite mais c'est
la seule dont on dispose c'est de se
transférer au dessus de zones protégées
sur ce qu'on appelle une orbite
cimetière leurs beats de parking et une
orbite d'euros bus situé au-delà de
l'orbité géo et enfin dans tous les cas
on demande
on ne voit pas bien sûr le sur la
planche là on demande de passive et les
satellites et les lanceurs en fin de
mission
or passive et ça veut dire les rendre
inertes
ça veut dire réduire toutes les sources
d'énergie à bord les airs gaulle les
pressions des batteries de manière à ce
que si on laisse un objet dans l'espace
c'est déjà embêtant des scènes objets
dans l'espace mais que au moins il ne
risque pas d'exploser plus tard sous
l'effet d'une collision ou sous l'effet
des changements thermique des passages
l'ombre des passages au soleil qui
pourrait entraîner des ruptures et
éventuellement des explosions
donc les mesures les plus efficaces et
la gestion de la fin de vie et la
passivation des objets qu'on laisse le
haut alors maintenant si on regarde le
s'intéresser aux futurs à plus long
terme on essaie de de calculer le ce que
sera la population dans dans plusieurs
années là on a une simulation qui a été
fait sur 200 ans en abscisse le temps
donc sur deux siècles et la courbe grise
qui donne le nombre d'objets catalogué
estimé d'après ces modèles qui est la
somme des des courbes verte rouge et
bleu ici qui sont les composantes en
rouge les collisions envers les
explosions ayant bleus les objets
intacte laissé en orbite
lorsqu'on voit tout de suite c'est que
sous l'effet des mesures de prévention
qui sont appliquées aujourd'hui les
courbes verte et bleue devrait non
seulement se stabiliser mais décroître
donc ça ça n'est un effet positif dû aux
mesures de prévention qu'on applique par
contre on s'aperçoit que la composante
rouge est en train de décoller ce qui
sait que la courbe la somme totale
risque de se documenter de cette manière
là et c'est la notion de réaction en
chaîne c'est-à-dire que les collisions
entre deux objets vont produire des
débris qui à leur tour vont produire des
collisions et c'est une espèce de
réaction en chaîne qui est aujourd'hui
amorcé qui a commencé un orbite basse
donc on sait que ce phénomène a démarré
aussi c'est pas un phénomène explosif
donc c'est très long vous voyez je sais
sur deux siècles mais c'est suffisamment
préoccupante pour que se pose la
question du nettoyage donc qu'il est à
peu près certain qu'un jour il faudra
être capable d'aller enlever des objets
dans l'espace pour faire pour faire du
nettoyage
voilà pour cette présentation
donc on a vu le problème des débris la
situation les risques bien évidemment
collision est retombée des objets les
solutions aujourd'hui sont pas très
nombreux si les affaires de de
prévention le les mesures de prévention
aujourd'hui sont par exemple dans la loi
française on a une loi sur l'espace qui
implique qu'ils obligeaient à appliquer
ces mesures de prévention et puis sur le
plus long terme ce sera les affaires de
nettoyage mais il est clair que si
aujourd'hui encore de la science fiction
parce que pour aller imaginer aller dans
l'espace chercher un objet l'attraper et
le ramener sur terre
c'est extrêmement compliqué il est aussi
extrêmement cher et la personne qui est
prêt à payer ce genre de manip
voilà merci